I'm going to start with congratulations
thank you thank you uh movie's fantastic
I'm so curious when Ryan first told you
about the movie and there was interest
however happened how much did he
actually tell you the story and what
would be happening and how much did he
say please read the script and let me
know what you think
he said the script
I just got a script
um and I was given like two days to read
it and uh and a zoom with Ryan and
that was pretty much it well along with
an NDA
is this the quickest you've said yes to
something
yes
yeah I think so
this is yes that was the fastest listen
the movie's fantastic and it's also very
funny when you were reading the script
did you realize how funny it was going
to be or was it the first time you saw
it with like an audience I
have to be on set as soon as Catherine
anytime Catherine opens him out you
realize oh she's gonna be hilarious and
same with Kate look everyone everyone
yes yeah you have a lot of nice
one-liners little tiny baby ones yeah no
I agree I think it was definitely when
we got on to set and I
um because the script was already
hilarious but um every everyone on this
cache just like just like stepped into
every character's shoes like so well and
um it's just so entertaining I think
yeah I think it was in watching
everybody's performances when you're
looking at the schedule and you see all
your scenes that you have to do which
was the day that you had circled as like
I cannot wait to film the sequence I
have scene was Kate which didn't make
the cut
I'm not allowed to talk about it Ryan
told me I'm not allowed to talk about it
I don't know why I just brought it up
that if so
I've seen my audition scene with Kate is
the scene in the bedroom
again hard to discuss without giving
spoilers but uh it was so much fun in my
audition I was I was excited to see how
she did it and she's so good so
um
I have one but I'm not gonna move it's a
spoiler
huh which one is it
no yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that makes
sense yeah yeah everyone watching this
is like what are they saying what is
this who can read lips let's put this
together but but okay so something you
can talk about is the fact that like you
never know when you're making a movie
how it's really going to turn out you
can have a great script and it's not
good this did so well at Tiff you know
it almost won the audience award and
like everyone loves it what does it mean
to be part of a film that is you know
everyone is just so enjoying it's
exciting it's really really exciting I
mean watching it in Toronto is
exhilarating to like have that like
First Watch through with an audience
I didn't have that shared experience in
the theater it was really special it's
nice to be something that part of
something that's so cinematic and just
fun and it kind of reminded me of when I
went to the cinema seat top gun Maverick
like everyone was just in uh commitment
commitment commitment that's what I felt
like in Toronto everyone's just along
for the ride yeah I am a big fan of
Ryan's work and I'm a big fan of uh his
Direction with all of his movies can you
talk a little bit about what he's
actually like on set when he had you
haven't done exactly what he wants is he
coming over in like is it a few words
how does he like to direct on set cute
he's a good he's an access director his
notes are very concise and small and a
lot of the time the note is just like
have more fun with it or yeah less fun
with it yeah or more bigger more and
more more and then you know a couple
times
um he's he's really I think he's really
really in tune to like how his actors
are feeling like a couple times he's
like let's take a walk and we would just
talk and we would just talk about it
that's nice you know and he would kind
of like he would give me
uh who kind of break down like what
specifically he was looking for
um in like certain moments and but then
but other times
um you know I he just let us play uh
last thing for you um which of your
friends and family were the most excited
that you got cast in Glass Onion my dad
hi Dad
stoic person so like when he shows
emotion or when he like even like just a
little bit raises his voice like I I
called him to tell him and he was just
like so giddy it was very sweet oh I
think my dad as well yeah my dad loves
murder mysteries trying to figure
something out alongside the audience and
uh same he's very stoic but he was
probably the most excited out of my
family on that note I have to go I'm
just going to say congrats thank you